i appreciate that the rock is bringing  back baggy clothes you know what i mean  like he wears [ __ ] that's like is he  have you seen his [ __ ] he'll he'll  put a suit on his shirt a shirt will be  tight right but his pants  holy [ __ ]  he's got some skin  how tall is he  is he tall also no no no he's four eight  he's four yeah yeah he's better yeah  they always have to stand really close  to camera so he seems big and the rest  of the cast is way far behind it okay  a long time ago i think it was like  season one of sunday and like some kid  was like oh what you do i'm like huh  he's like what do you do i'm like i  don't know like i'm an actor he's like  you ever met vin diesel i'm like oh yeah  dude he's like he is he badass like no  he's really small so what are you  talking about like he's really tiny man  he's like  what about those those cars he drives  they make tiny cars for they make like  tiny little  [Music]